we're breaking into our scheduled
broadcasting of course to bring you that
top story coming out of Iraq and that
the Iraqi president says that he is
willing to resign rather than name a
prime minister that is being rejected by
protesters let's get more on this from
our correspondent in the Iraqi capital
Baghdad jaw's dosa Jabari joins me on
the phone and door sir we're just
getting this news in that president
Saleh is certainly making a statement
that will resonate across the country
and certainly right down to Basra where
the PM candidate sits yes absolutely
well we just heard from his office the
president's office that his letter of
resignation is now being submitted to
the Parliament and that's because he's
been under a tremendous amount of
pressure from the various parties and
coalition groups within the Parliament
to try and come up with a candidate that
will please all sides
you know the protesters on the streets
as well as the parties as well as the
Alliance's that the parties have fought
with not only other groups with same
problem with outside parties as well
that has a vested interest in this
country the president has said in the
past that if he's not able to find a
suitable candidate to nominate to form a
government he will resign so we knew
that this might be a possibility but it
certainly does not expect this to happen
sorry dosa is the pressure really coming
from the public as such on the president
or does the president in a loose term
have an agenda himself about the type of
prime minister that you were taking up
office in light of the civil unrest that
we've seen across the country no as far
as we understand the president has been
trying to align his interest with those
of the people on the streets and we know
that he has had the backing and support
of the clerical establishment in Iraq
that comes from that that has very
powerful
for influence across the country so we
know that he wanted to try and find the
candidates that was going to clean that
side the people and that is something
that I was just virtually impossible
because the Constitution here states
that the ruling coalition party in
parliament has to nominate a candidate
and the president really doesn't have a
say in how that candidate is selected
it's up to the ruling majority parties
in Parliament so constitutionally he
didn't have much power he had to
nominate whoever was given to him by
that group and that on Wednesday that
group which is the Albin ah coalition
who can Parliament that is made up of
foods that are backed by Iran had
nominated the governor of Basra and the
president did not announce that
candidate as the next prime minister and
we believe that to be that he was going
to do that either today or maybe some
point tomorrow that he was just waiting
to find out how people would react to
that nomination but it was very very
clear early on as soon as we heard the
name of that Governor that is has laid
on you the governor that saw that the
people were adamant that they will not
accept that decision you know boxer has
had protests way before we've seen any
of that in Baghdad Bachar is one of the
courts country and provinces in Iraq
even though it has 70% of the country's
oil reserves and major oil fields are
from that province but it really major
the main infrastructure doesn't exist in
that College this is one of the reasons
people have been demonstrating for well
over a year there and they're adamant
that this governor is not part of what
the people on the streets want to be in
government so his decision really the
president's decision violence are not to
go ahead with nominating with announcing
the nomination for the prime minister
was in as a trying an effort to really
approve the people the public that say
they don't want a prime minister who
listen to their needs and demands and
they want to be able to elect their
prime
but unfortunately the country's
Constitution is based on a parliamentary
system and not a presidential one which
is what the demonstrator can want it and
that's what they've been fighting for in
October and the world were 480 people
have lost their lives trying to change
the system the constitution of the
country the Constitution was written in
2005 after many many consultations were
held with various legal groups and the
people of Iraq voted there was a
referendum on this Constitution so they
were a part of the process initially but
now since then they say that the country
has become so corrupt and open to
outside influences namely that of Iran
in the United States that they can no
longer tolerate the system it's not good
enough for them they want to be able to
have the kind of standard of life that
they're entitled to Iraqis or catch
second largest producer of oil over four
and a half million barrels of oil a
producer in Iraq and yet when you are in
the country we don't see that money
anywhere it's not in the infrastructure
or anywhere in this in the country this
is what is the main point of contention
core Iraqis they say they should be able
to have the standard of life that they
want even the wealth that is available
in their country indeed we'll talk about
sort of the technocrats and how a new
candidate could be certainly put into
position as the prime minister but if we
talk about and you touched upon it about
outside influence in internal Iraqi
affairs part of the the gripe you might
say that the public have is about
external influence is about the
influence of Iran and this particular
candidate Adani has been nominated by
you might say the Iranian supported bloc
of parliament what is that relationship
on the ground in society at the moment
about the relationship between Iraqis
and Iranian between Iraqi politicians
that have the support of Iranian styled
either clerics or politicians from
across the border well I think it's a
very complicated relationship
she's very difficult to to say but the
one thing that is certain is that there
is a very strong anti Iranian feeling
that is present in Iraq we've seen the
attacks that were carried out against
the Iranian consulate in Madras and
Karbala where they set fire to those
buildings and people made it very clear
that they did not want Iran's assistance
or influence in their country and more
now Iran and Iraq have had also a very
tumultuous relationship they were at war
with each other in the 1980s for eight
years and then after that following the
fall of Saddam Hussein there was an
opportunity for a relationship to forge
between the two sides and that's what
happened to be that's when things they
became much closer and with the rise of
ISIL in northern Iraq the Iranians came
to the help of the Iraqis at that time
under Nuri al-maliki as a prime minister
and they helped the Iraqis fight ISIL in
many parts of this country that is
really when they became much much closer
and they have a very long and strong
economic relationship as well they share
a very large border between each other
and they have thirteen billion dollars
worth of trade between the two countries
so they say that this relationship is
very very important to them and if some
continue but now the feeling on the
trees is that they no longer want the
Iranians to dictate to them and how
their country should run politically
they don't want any kind of powers to
the exert annex from one side or the
other and that's really what we see a
lot on the truth now it didn't of course
when we come to the potential candidates
for the position of prime minister
speaking to us on the al Jazeera news
hour a short while ago was Marwan Kabul
on a senior analyst here in Doha
and he was talking about the fact that
there are many technocrats in Iraq it
was a very well disciplined very well
educated country in the days of Saddam
Hussein these people did exist yet the
only people that are coming to the
forefront of those with a great deal of
either economic or political baggage
with titles of corruption added to it
that the people are very aware of why
are these technocrats not you might say
visible to the public at large or why
are they not coming forward is there a
reason for that well a huge brain drain
over the past few years many of those
people have left the country there's
just not that much interest in them
coming back and taking part in the
political process but this is one of the
main problems that this president is
facing and that led to his resignation
because the protesters the other
political parties they wanted a
candidate to replace other of the nation
who wasn't part of the political process
and that is something that is very hard
to find I would say virtually impossible
you have to really bring somebody in
from outside of Iraq is that what you
wanted to do and that on its own
proposes a series of challenges under
these circumstances I think this is one
of the major issues that the protesters
were adamant about they wanted somebody
who wasn't establishment in the country
that they didn't have a candidate either
so it wasn't like there was another
option and this is what was the most
difficult point for the president and
this is I believe one of the reasons I'm
led to him being forced to resign
because he was under tremendous pressure
to accept one of these candidates there
was three candidates over the past week
that would put to him by Albin our
coalition and Parliament's and susan's
accept any of them who said he would not
could that mean Ford and announced that
those names and candidates as the next
prime minister because he knew that the
people on the streets would not accept
that and that would mean further unrest
and insecurity it would be unleashed
across the country
so I think he just at this point felt
that he had no other option to resign
and under the Constitution this is not
clear what will happen next because
their Constitution has not separated
when the president resigned or the Prime
Minister resigned those women opposed to
become vacant so know that the whole
establishment the spokespersons for
grand ayatollah ali Sistani during last
week's Friday players in car the log
said that there must be elections held
immediately so that's what the country
really needs at this point but the issue
is the Iraqi parliament and the
Electoral Commission in the country had
said that they need at least between six
months for one year to be able to hold
elections in the country for logistical
and security leave them so they're not
equipped to let's say go to the polls in
a month or anything to that effect so
it's very very unclear what will happen
next
and we know that the outgoing Prime
Minister as a lot domestic is still in
office he's the in caretaker Prime
Minister he's still holding his weekly
cabinet sessions he's still conducting a
job in YouTube because there hasn't been
a replacement for him so this
resignation now of the president just
makes things much much more unclear and
of course the issue of what happens next
is perhaps the the big unknown question
this is you might say new new ground a
new route a new reality that the Iraqi
political establishment and the public
at large have never experienced before
you touched on it with no sort of viable
prime minister and with a potentially
that the president if you can't be sort
of talked out of it having resigned who
takes charge of the country even though
you have a caretaker Prime Minister it
really does leave the country leaderless
yes and that is something that is very
very dangerous
sane Iraq at the moment to create your
political vacuum which in turn could
pass
creates a security vacuum because there
are very various different groups and
the house armed we in Iraq they are also
part of the government in Parliament so
without clear leadership there will be a
sense that these groups could try and
assert their own power over one another
and this is something that had happened
in the past and this was certainly a
lorry of many amulets and smoke stood
here for the past few weeks that the
this uncertainty just creates that kind
of vacuum for these issues to play
themselves out and that is what the
president was trying to avoid and even
the Grand Ayatollah Sistani had
mentioned that this is something that
should be avoided we cannot have this
kind of power of vacuum in the country
because it creates such security
instability in this country so this is
why they were trying to find the
candidate but they failed clearly so now
this is something that will be very very
important for the security apparatuses
because also according to the
Constitution the Prime Minister is the
commander-in-chief of the armed forces
in the country so we the caretaker Prime
Minister he still technically available
make me in charge of the country's
security forces now with the president's
resignation we don't know how he will
move forward what his next move will be
as well it could be enough of truly for
him to use to stay off until they can
hold elections in Iraq well of course
we'll continue to monitor events there
are more stamens that are coming out of
the Iraqi capital as the day progresses
for the moment dose of Jabari they are
correspondent in Baghdad thank you